ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่แอดตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครับผมสวัสดีกลับมานะ
ครับกลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยน้ากับเพียร์ตีกับ
น้องเรียมเนาะ
ต้องคอมเพรนสะโบไทยเย้
เจคอบ
แค่เรามาเรียนกันนะครับภาษาไทยการวันนี้
วันนี้เรามาเรียนกันวันอะไรครับวันนี้วัน
เสาร์วันนี้อ้าวันนี้วันเสาร์โอเคครับวัน
เสาร์วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันที่ 22
ค่ะวันที่
22 วันนี้วันเสาร์วันที่ 22 แล้วอ้าวัน
ที่ 22 เดือนอะไรครับเดือนมกราคมเดือน
มกราคมนะครับโอเคแล้วปีเสือคศอะไรครับข้อ
2 ต.ค
R2 พันธุ์ 22 หากคศในคัพ 2022 แล้วปีคศ
อะไรครับพ.ต.
2565 ค่ะ 5
2565 โอเคปีนี้ปีนี้ปีคศ 2010  22 ใช่
ไหม
2022  5 ปีนี้ 2,000  22 ปีที่แล้วปีที่
แล้วปีพศ.อะไรครับปีที่แล้ว
คศ
2000  21
2021  5 ถูกต้องครับแล้วปีหน้าน่ะครับปี
หน้าปีหน้าปีพศ.อะไรครับจีน่าคอตต์ตั้ง
ครรภ์ 23 ค่ะอ่า
2023 เป็นปีหน้าสมัยมีนาไม่ใช่ปีนี้ปี
นี้ 2,000  22
ขอแค่โอเคครับอ้าแล้วตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้อ่า
เรามาเรียนกันกี่โมงครับกี่โมงนะกี่โมง
ครับตอนนี้ดูนาฬิกาใช่มั้ยน้องเรียมดู
นาฬิกาข้อมือ
นาฬิกาข้อมือตอนนี้กี่โมงครับ
13:15 นา 13:00 น 15 นาทีนะครับอ่าบ่าย
โมงบ่ายโมงบ่ายโมง 5 บาทฮ่าๆๆโอ้โห 15
นาทีตอนบ่ายเป็นตอนกลางวันใช่ไหมอ้าวบ่าย
โมง 55 นาทีหัวหน้าโอเคครับ 5 แล้วตอนนี้
ตอนนี้บ่ายโมง 15 นาทีแล้ว R ถ้าอีก 2
ชั่วโมงอีก 2 ชั่วโมง
อีก 2 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงกี่โมงครับ 2
ชั่วโมงจะเป็นกี่โมงจะเป็น 15:00 นาอีก 2
ชั่วโมงก็ใช่
หนึ่งตรงนี้
2 ใช่มั้ยก็จะเป็น
บ่าย 3 โมงน้อ Oh  Okay อีก 2 ชั่วโมง
เป็นบ่าย3โมงหน้าที่ 15 ครับแล้ว
แล้วครับซึ่งชั่วโมงหนึ่งชั่วโมงที่แล้ว
คือกี่โมง
ชั่วโมงที่แล้วใช่ไหมอ่ะตอนนี้ตอนนี้เรา
อยู่ตรงนี้ตอนนี้ 13:00 นใช่ไหม 1
ชั่วโมงคะแล้วก็กลับไปกลับไป 1 ชั่วโมง
อ้าก็คือตรงนี้ครับ
5  1 ชั่วโมงที่แล้วเป็นตอน
เที่ยง
ตอนเที่ยงคนไทยเรียกเที่ยงใช่ครับ
12:15 นใช่ครับ
ตอนเที่ยงเตรียมก็กินข้าวอ่ะทรายเพียงพี่
ก็กินข้าวตอนเที่ยงเหมือนกันตอนเที่ยงเรา
กินข้าวนะครับหน้าโรงเรียนกินข้าวตอนไหน
บ้างครับ
เตรียมกินข้าวตอนเช้าตอนนี้เจ็ดโมงเช้า 7
โมงเช้าหรอตอนตอนนี้อ่าเจ็ดโมงเช้ากิน
ข้าวเรียกเช้ากินข้าวเช้าหรอโอเคกินข้าว
เช้าแล้วก็ตอนเที่ยงใช่มากินข้าวอะนี้กิน
ข้าวอะไรครับกินข้าวเที่ยงอ้ากินข้าว
เที่ยงล่ะโอเคอ่ะแล้วอะมีกินข้าวอีกไหม
ครับกินข้าวกี่ครั้งครับกินข้าว 3 ครั้ง
ค่ะ 3 ครั้งมีตอนเช้านะ 7:00 นรับตอน
เที่ยงนะครับตอนเที่ยงกินอีก 1 ครั้งแล้ว
กินตอนไหนครับกินตอน 17:00 นตอน
นี้ 5 โมงเย็นกินอีก 1 ครั้งอ๋ออ๋อโอเค
กิน 3 ครั้งหนึ่งวันหนึ่งวันกิน 3 ครั้ง
อ๋อโอเคโอเคเพลียปีก็กิน 3 ครั้งเหมือน
กัน
ตายค่ะพี่กินข้าวตอน 17:00 นไหมคะเฮียตี๋
มากินข้าวตอนเอ่อ 20:00 นครับ
ผ่อนนี้
08:00 นไลน์ครับเตรียมกินข้าวตอน 17:00
นเรียกว่า
กินข้าวเย็น
เบียร์ตีกินตอน 8:00 นพี่ก็เรียกข้าวเย็น
ฮ่า
ๆอ้าวเย็นเหมือนกัน
เที่ยวที่กินข้าวเช้ามั้ยคะกินข้าวเช้า
ครับ
เฮียติ๊กกินข้าวเช้าตอน
08:00 นล้อ
8:00 นๆกับกินก่อน 8:00 นมาก็กินข้าว
เช้า
กับกินข้าวตอนเช้าเรียกกินข้าวเช้าอาเจ้
วันนี้ครับวันนี้ฮะเล่าเรียนเรื่องอะไร
กันคะวันนี้ขอ
หวยคือเจ็บใช่มั้ย of เจ็บ
ปวดแค่เจ็บแล้วก็ปวดเหมือนกันมั้ยเหมือน
ไหมเจ็บเรียมคิดว่า
ไม่เหมือนแต่ได้ขายเจ็บ
จิ๊ดเจ็บเจ็บ
เจ็บขอข้างนี้ตั้งนี่เจ็บ
โอเคอ่าเจ็บมามีเจ็บอะไรบ้างครับที่เราจะ
เป็นมาดูกันว่าเจ็บปวดคืออะไรน่าดีเจ็บมี
ปวดอะไรบ้างเพราะเคครับ
R ครับ
ค่ะวันนี้เห็นอะไรบ้างคะที่เห็นผู้ชายมี
ผู้ชาย 1 คนผู้ชายคนนี้เอามือเอามือจับ
ไหล่เอามือกับลายหน้าเพชรอีกคิดว่าคิดว่า
ผู้ชายคนนี้เจ็บเจ็บไหล่ใช่ไหม
เจ็บไหล่ 5 ใช่ไหมครับเจ็บไหล่ใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะเจ็บลายเด็กไหล่
เจ็บลาย้อนนี้คือเจ็บใหม่
โอเคบางคนก็พูดว่าปวดไหล่ขอพูดว่าเจ็บลาย
พูดว่าปวดไหล่เหมือนกันเหมือนกันใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะเย่หาเฮียตี้เคยปวดล่ะใช่ไหมคะอ่า
เพื่อติ๊กเคยเคยปวดไหล่ครับปวดไหล่เวลา 5
รหัส Theater ๆไปฉีดฉีดวัคซีน
ยุติไปเปลี่ยนนะฉีดวัคซีนโอเคอ่ะ
ที่วัคซีน
อาชีพวัคซีนเข้าไปทางทิศข้างนี้ที่นี่
ครอบครัว
ปวดไหล่ที่ฉีดวัคซีน 5 ใส่ครับเค้าจะอยู่
แถวนี้ใช่ไหมคะ 5 ไส้ครับจะอยู่แถวนี้แถว
นี้ส่งที่ฉีดตายได้ขับน้องเรียม R ที่
วัคซีนแล้วน้องเรียมปวดไหล่ไหมปวดไหมปวด
ค่ะอย่า
ปวดเหมือนกันอ่ะโอเคโอเคหรือบางครั้งถ้า
เฮียตี้ยกของยกของหนักๆแบบ
ถ้าของหนักหนักมีดีก็ปวดปวดไหล่ได้หลาย
หรือ
ว่าเรียมมีกระเป๋า
กระเป๋าสะพายกระเป๋า
ใช่นานสะพายถนัดนอนหนักๆนานๆนานๆแล้วก็
หนัก
อาหาร 10 กิโลกรัม 10 กิโลกรัมหนักหนา
แล้วก็สะพายนันๆด้วยฮะก็จะเป็นนานไหล่ปวด
ไหล่ค่ะน้อขอแค่ปวดไหล่หรือเจ็บไปเหมือน
กันแก้แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับ
มี
เพียบที่เห็นอะไรคะอ่ะนี่อ่าที่เห็น
เหมือนมีผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคนนี้มีผู้หญิง R15
ก็นี้กำลังมือจับที่ตรงนี้ตรงนี้เรียกคอ
คอหาหาคอก็มิติคิดว่าอันนี้เรียกว่าเจ็บ
เจ็บคอเจ็บคอคอให้ครับ
ถ้าเกิดเตรียม
i5 ทรายครับก็จะเจ็บของข้อ 5 คนเป็นโค
วิชคนเป็นข้อผิดเขาเจ็บคอไม่ให้ไปขอ
เป็นหรือเปล่าแล้วเนี่ยมันเป็นไหมไม่ค่ะ
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนไออ๋อ
โอเค
ตอนนี้ไม่อายอ๋ออ๋อไม่เจ็บแล้วไม่ใจอ่อน
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าบางคนก็
แก้ปวดคอ
ขอปวดคออาจจะปวดตรงนี้ตรงนี้ก็ได้ด้าน
ข้างตรงนี้ใช่ไหมปวดคอหาเวลาที่เรานอนนอน
เวลาที่เรานอนแล้วนอนบนนอนบนหมอนใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะได้เบียร์ตีวาดรูปหมอหน้านี่หมอน
อยู่นะครับ
นอนหมดสอนและก็เวลานอนเวลานอนหมอนหมอน
หลุดออกไป
หารู้จะไปตรงโน้นเดี๋ยวก็ยังนอนอยู่ไม่มี
หมอเลยทีก็ตื่นมาไปแล้วตื่นมาก็จะเปลี่ยน
คอ
หมอนหนีออกไป
ปวดคอปวดขอขวดคอน้าทรายครับพี่หรือว่า
เรียงทำงานทำงานแล้วก็กลุ่มหน้าอ๋ออาจกรม
นั้นมันๆถ้านานๆ
เราจะปวด
ปวดคอปวดคอคอฮ่าฮ่าใช้ครับ
แล้วก็มี
ท่ามยายครับมีเมื่อกี้มีต่อเจ็บไหล่ใช่
ไหมมีเจ็บคอปวดคอแล้วมีอันนี้อะไรครับ
เครียดที่เห็นอะไรคะอะเพื่อที่เห็นผู้ชาย
คนนี้กำลังเอามือจับจับที่ท้องท้องตรงนี้
ครับขอ
อ้าผู้ชายก็นี้กำลัง City คิดว่าแบบนี้
เรียกว่าปวดปวดของหน้าปวดท้องปวดท้องได้
ครับ 5 ปวดของอ่ะ
theatre ที่อร่อยครับๆเคยปวดท้องไหมคะ
เพี้ยนติ๊กเคยพี่นี่เคยปวดท้องนะครับอ้ะ
ปวดท้องอ๊ะป่าวเวลาที่เวลาที่อะพี่ตี้หิว
ข้าวหิวข้าวมากๆถึงตอนเที่ยงยังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวตอนบ่ายโมงยังไม่ได้กินข้าวอ๋อพี่ทำ
งานไม่ได้กินข้าวนี่ก็จะเริ่มปวด
ท้อง 5 ปวดท้องๆครับหน้าหรือว่าข้าวหิว
ข้าวทรายทำไม่ได้กินข้าวเราก็จะปวดท้อง
ใช้ทำงงเรียมเคยปวดท้องนะครับ 5 น้อง
เรียนไปทำอะไรทำไมถึงปวดท้องครับทำไมปวด
ผอมกิน
กินข้าวอาจไม่ดี
พอๆคินข้าวไม่ดีอ่า
ใช่เรื่องก็ขวดไม่ดีก็คืออ่าอาหารที่กิน
เข้าไปเนี่ย We  Are มันเสียแล้วใช่ไหม
ไส้ไม่ดีอีกๆใช่ครับเวลากินเข้าไปก็จะปวด
ท้อง
โอเคได้
เตรียมเตรียมกินอ๋ออ๋อไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่า
อาหารไม่รู้ว่าอาหารไม่ดีอาหารเสียแล้ว
ปวดคอก็เลยปวดท้อง
โอเคใช่
ถ้าอาหารเสียกินเข้าไปปวดท้อง
บางคนไทยว่าท้องเสีย
ใช่ครับท้องเสีย
ท้องเสียเพราะว่ากินกินอาหาร
อาหารเสียอะกินอาหารเสียท้องก็เสียใช่
ครับใช่มากโอเค
ของเรียมท้องเสียแต่ว่าพี่อาร์ตี้ปวดท้อง
ปวดท้องอ่าหิวข้าว
ปวดท้องนะโอเคเวลาขับข้าวได้ยินเสียงอะไร
ไหมคะข้อใช่ครับตีก็จะได้ยินเสียงท้อง
ร้องของร้อง
5  2 ร้องจ๊อกๆแบบนี้ได้ครับออกของ
จ๊อกๆหิวข้าวหิวข้าวท้องของบอกท้องบอก
อยู่ข้าวหิวข้าวเสียงที่ได้ยินเสียงจ๊อก
จ๊อกจ๊อกๆ
ใช่อาคนไทยพูด 5 ของร้องจ๊อกจ๊อก
ได้ยินเสียงจ้อกได้ไซเขาดอกๆๆ
[เพลง]
ฮะโอเคเพียบที่ต้องไปกลับไปกินข้าวนะคะ
เราไม่กินข้าวใช่ครับของจะได้ไม่ร้องจะ
ได้ไม่จะได้ไม่ปวดของขวดเก็บไปค่ะ
แล้วก็
นี่
อ้ามีอะไรครับวันนี้ป่วยอะไรอ่ะตรงนี้มี
อะไรอยู่
วันนี้มีอะไรอยู่ตรงนี้คือหน้าอกหน้าอก
ใช่มั้ยอ่าหน้าอกตรงนี้หน้าอกหน้า
อะไรอะไรคะๆเห็นผู้ชายคนนี้กำลังเอา
มือจับจับที่หน้าอกเนี่ยอาจจะเป็นตรงนี้
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้ก็ได้เจ็บเรียกเรียกเจ็บเจ็บ
หน้าอกหน้าหรือเจ็บ 5 เจ็บหน้าอกซ้ายครับ
เจ็บอยู่ข้างในอยู่ทั้งในตัวเจ็บอยู่ข้าง
ในเจ็บหน้าอกรับ
สายเขา
r7 หน้าอกมือ
ข้างในเข้าไปอาจจะมีหัวใจใช่ไหมคะถ้ามี
หัวใจใช้ครับ
เจ็บเจ็บหัวใจเหรอครับไป
ฮ่าๆ
เจ็บใจอ่ะโอเคอ่าไม่เกี่ยวกันไม่เกี่ยว
กันอันนี้เจ็บหน้าอกนะครับพอเจ็บหน้าอก
เจ็บหน้าอกเขทำไมถึงเจ็บหน้าอกครับทำไม
ทำไมเจ็บหน้าอก
เพราะว่าเตรียมเคยเจ็บหน้าอก
ขับจะมีหัวใจใช่ไหมคะเราก็เส้นเลือด
เส้นเลือดเราก็มีไขมันอ๋อ
ไขมันที่อยู่ในเส้นเลือดหา
ไขมันไขมันเยอะๆ
อยู่ในเส้นเลือด
ใช่ค่ะก็เลยรู้สึกเจ็บหน้าอกหมอมีไขมัน
เยอะทำให้เจ็บหน้าอกใช่ตอนนั้นเตรียมกิน
ขี่โต
ฮะกินขี้โตโอเคกับแล้วก็กินแบบเนื้อสัตว์
เนื้อสัตว์
มากอ๋อ
มาหากินเนื้อหมู
[เพลง]
อ้ามันทับอยู่ครับ
รุ่นโรงเรียนมันอยู่ข้างหลังอ้าโอเค
อ่าได้แล้ว
กินหมูเยอะไม่ดีอยากกินเนื้อเยอะไม่ดีนะ
อ่าๆต้องกินไม่
รวมตอนนั้นตอนนั้นเรียมไม่ไม่กินผักให้
กินผักก็ไม่ดีดีไม่ดีต้องกินผักด้วย
ใช่ค่ะถ้าอย่างนี้
กินครับขี่โตจะรู้ขอโอเคแต่ตอนนี้ไม่เจ็บ
หน้าอกแล้วใช่ไหมครับไม่เจ็บแล้วไม่เจ็บ
แล้วค่ะเย้ดีครับ
แล้วก็มี
มีอะไรครับมิดเจ็บอะไรอีกครับอีกสักอย่าง
นึงอ่ะ
ติดอะไรนะเจ็บคออันนี้เจ็บหน้าอกใช่ไหม
ครับอ่ะตามรูปเจ็บ
และอีก
อ๋อ
อันนี้นิเจ็บเจ็บอะไรครับตรงนั้นขาใช่ไหม
ใช่น่าจะขาเจ็บขา
หน้าใช่ครับ
ผู้ชายคนนี้กำลังเจ็บขา
เจ็บขาแต่ถ้าเกิดเจ็บตรงนี้ล่ะคะเจ็บตรง
ไหนครับตรงนั้นตรงนั้นเรียกว่าเข่าข่าว
ได้หายเจ็บเข่า
ซ้ายครับ
เทียบดีเคยเจ็บเขาไหมคะเพชรตี้เคยเคยเจ็บ
เข่าเจ็บเข่าเวลาที่เพียงตีวิ่งวิ่งเยอะๆ
วิ่งนาน
ๆจะดีวิ่งมาราธอนนานๆเฮียตีก็จะมีรู้สึก
เจ็บเข่าซ้ายครับตัวผู้ 5 เจ็บเข่า 10
เข้า
แล้วพี่อาร์ตี้เคยเจ็บขาไหมคะหน้าเคยเจ็บ
ขาเหมือนกันครับเคยเจ็บขาถ้าหากบางครั้ง
เราเดินไปเดินไปแล้วก็ชนคนโต๊ะชนเอ่อของ
แข็งๆชนประตูบ้านเราก็จะเจ็บเจ็บขาทราย
แฮปปี้เดินเดิน
ชนประตูบ้านอาหารใช่ครับไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
ประตูเล็กมากเมื่อกี้เห็นประตูนี่คือ
ประตูนะคะเฮียตีก็เดินเดินแล้วก็ไปชน
โซนาร์ได้ครับบางทีบางทีประตูก็อ่าเปิด
ปิดเองได้เขาไปช่วงที่ลมมีลมพัดพัดลมพัด
วียืนที่ประตูลมพัดประตูประตูก็ปิดก้น
หน้าประตูก็ปิดมาโดนขามาโดนขายนี่
มันยืนอยู่
เขาเจ็บขา
15  5
โอเควันนี้มีเจ็บอะไรบ้างครับทบทวนหน่อย
วัน Army  7 ขานี่เจ็บขาไม่ครับขา
5 แล้วก็มีเจ็บเจ็บเข่าได้ใช่ไหมเจ็บ
ข่าวช่าแย่มีเจ็บขาเจ็บข่าวแล้วก็มีอ่า 5
เจ็บหน้าอกเจ็บหน้าอก
เกครับหาแล้วก็มี
เจ็บท้องอ่าปวดท้องหรือเจ็บคออ่างกับเจ็บ
ท้องแล้วก็มีเออท้องเสียด้วยใช่ไหมท้อง
เสียโอเคใครมีแฟนเสียหายคะแล้วก็
อ้านี้เจ็บคอเจ็บคอเคครับเจ็บคอเวลาไอ
หรือว่า
ปวดขอบคุณไม่ได้พูดไม่ได้เจ็บเพราะเจ็บคอ
ขวดคอ 5 ได้ครับ
ขวดข้องเราก็มี
หน้านี้เจ็บไหล่ใช่ไหมเจ็บไหล่นะโอเคลาย
ขวดใหญ่
ชายค่ะ ka วันนี้เราก็ได้เรียนรู้เรื่อง
ของการเจ็บปวดนะครับไปแล้วนะครับเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้านะเราจะกลับมาเรียนเรื่องอะไรกัน
เดี๋ยวค่อยติดตามครับพี่อาร์ตี้กับน้อง
เรียมในช่องคอมเพลนเซิร์ฟเวอร์ไทยนะครับ
ใช่ค่ะวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วเวลาหมดแล้ว
เดี๋ยวพี่กับน้องเรียนต้องลีลาแต่ก่อน
ครับใครค่ะของหน้าสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะเบียร์ตี้บ๊ายบาย
นักเรียนได้มากขึ้น